aquí he dibujado un anillo cuadrado de
un conductor digamos que es un alambre
está estacionario y se encuentra en un
campo magnético y he dibujado algunos
vectores para representar este campo
magnético y los pueden ver al menos en
la superficie que está definida o
contorneada por este alambre y vemos que
el campo magnético luce constante
tenemos este escenario realmente no está
pasando nada muy especial que digamos
pero se vuelve interesante si yo cambio
el flujo que pasa por esta superficie
estos otros dos dibujos muestran el
mismo escenario en donde hemos
incrementado el flujo si vemos estos
puntos de nuestro campo magnético en
este ejemplo los vemos en los demás
escenarios y estos vectores están más
grandes hemos aumentado el flujo
magnético hemos aumentado el flujo y el
campo magnético se ha vuelto más fuerte
vamos a escribirlo el flujo y aquí
usamos la letra griega
para denotar el flujo el flujo del campo
magnético be ha aumentado y sabemos a
partir de la ley de faraday que cuando
tenemos un cambio en el flujo nos va a
inducir una corriente en el circuito o
en este anillo la pregunta interesante
aquí es qué dirección va a tener esta
corriente tenemos dos opciones la
corriente puede ir en sentido horario
como lo estoy dibujando aquí o puede ir
en sentido antihorario como lo estoy
dibujando aquí abajo
cuál de estos dos creen ustedes será la
dirección que tome la corriente
pensemos en ello sabemos que la
corriente que va por un alambre por sí
sola va a inducir un campo magnético
independientemente del campo magnético
que ya tenemos aquí pensemos en qué tipo
de campo magnético nos va a generar esta
corriente dependiendo de la dirección si
va en sentido antihorario usamos la
regla de la mano derecha tomo mi mano
derecha mi pulgar va a apuntar hacia la
dirección de la corriente y los demás
dedos de esa mano me van a indicar el
sentido del campo magnético que genera
esa corriente
veamos dibujo mi pulgar en dirección de
la corriente y mis dedos me van a
indicar hacia dónde iría el campo
magnético
esto lo hago con mi mano derecha que más
o menos dibuje así y vemos que el campo
magnético inducido tiene esta dirección
y si tomáramos algunos puntos de
muestreo de esta corriente inducida en
nuestro anillo se vería algo así y aquí
lo dibujo sólo en algunos puntos de
muestreo que me interesa noten que estos
se van a sumar al campo magnético que ya
existe y esto ocasionaría que este flujo
se incrementará aún más estos vectores
se harían más grandes y esto a su vez
que va a ocasionar bueno si aumenta el
flujo pues la corriente también va a
aumentar que va a hacer que aumente el
campo magnético que a su vez va a
incrementar el flujo y de nuevo me va a
incrementar la corriente y tendremos
este ciclo sin fin en donde la corriente
va a incrementar el flujo y a su vez el
flujo va a incrementar la corriente y
tendríamos energía que aparentemente
surge de la
lo que violaría a la ley de la
conservación de la energía así que esto
no puede ocurrir así que con esto
podemos descartar este escenario la
corriente no puede ir en sentido
antihorario pues la corriente inducida
no nos puede incrementar o aumentar el
flujo del campo magnético y por
deducción podemos darnos cuenta que lo
que va a ocurrir es el escenario de
arriba veamos qué pasa aquí hacemos de
nuevo nuestra regla de la mano derecha
nuestro pulgar va a indicar la dirección
de la corriente inducida nuestros dedos
van a indicar el sentido del campo
magnético asociado a esta corriente y
vemos que si hacemos esto el campo
magnético que esta corriente induce va a
decrementar el flujo que tenemos aquí
esa corriente produce un flujo magnético
que va en sentido contrario del campo
magnético que ya tengo aquí y cuando la
corriente pasa por acá de nuevo usamos
nuestra regla de la mano derecha el
pulgar indica el sentido de la corriente
que aquí es en sentido horario aquí
también nuestros dedos se van a curvar
hacia abajo y de nuevo si vemos la
superficie va a inducir un campo
magnético que va en esta dirección hacia
abajo el campo magnético inducido por la
corriente inducida va a ir en sentido
contrario al del flujo original lo cual
tiene sentido ya que esto evita que
entremos en un ciclo infinito de aumento
de energía en el que nuestra corriente
va a aumentar cada vez más y a su vez
nos va a inducir mayor campo magnético
que seguiría aumentando cada vez más
esta idea de que la orientación de la
corriente que es inducida por este campo
va a su vez producir un campo magnético
que va a contrarrestar el campo
magnético original y a esto le llamamos
la ley de lens y nuevamente si esto no
se cumpliera tendríamos una violación a
la ley de la conservación de la energía
así que en general cuando alguien diga
que este es el cambio de flujo que está
ocurriendo en este
si nos preguntamos en qué sentido viaja
la corriente simplemente tenemos que
pensar en qué tipo de campo magnético va
a contrarrestar el flujo original así
que si aumenta el flujo magnético el
campo magnético inducido por la
corriente inducida va a ir en el sentido
opuesto y hará que el flujo disminuya en
el caso de que el flujo esté
disminuyendo
entonces el campo magnético inducido por
la corriente inducida hará que el flujo
disminuya menos o se sumará al flujo